can you stay for a few message Airy web
is on the line from San Jose and if you
want to stay and talk about this article
I need some some help here Gary where
were you there this morning yeah I am
good morning good morning you how are
you very tired really I apologize you're
really nice to do this we've had so many
calls about this is why we asked you to
do it well I'm happy to talk about I
actually heard you on a radio station
when I was in Detroit a couple weeks ago
for about an hour talking about this
this is what it's all about it's a San
Jose Mercury News and here's a
front-page piece in August 8th August
the 18th and it's the first of a
three-part series tell us you know in a
couple minutes what this is about it's
about it's about a drug ring that
operated in San Francisco and Los
Angeles be in the mid 80s and it was it
was connected to a Nicaraguan
anti-communist army called the SDN which
was one of the biggest groups who we
know as Contras and it was selling
cocaine in Los Angeles for the most part
but in other areas of the country as
well to the gains to the Crips and
bloods down in los down in South Central
Los Angeles and they were taking the
money and using some of it I don't know
how much we have figured that out yet to
buy weapons for the Contras and you know
I know I know it's I know it sounds
crazy I know it sounds like the wildest
conspiracy theories which is why all our
supporting documentation for the thing
is posted on the internet if anybody's
interested I can give you the Internet
address later on yeah we've got a from
the Mercury News here a big chart that
you put together from the Sunday story
did you write all this by the way it did
this is a chart that shows how the the
money left down around Colombia and can
you give us a little bit of this
scenario I'm not looking at a television
right now but is that the pipeline sure
is uh yeah those are the various
smuggling routes that that the ring used
starting late seventies up to the early
90s to get the cocaine into the country
and to get the money had some of the
money back out of the country and
indepent do depending on the year and
depending on the the you know how
intense the police
he was which wasn't very most part that
those are different routes they use they
use the freighters they use stolen cars
they would just fly the stuff in in
suitcases early on when you didn't bring
very much in let me read the first one
up here which is right near Los Angeles
it says mid-1970s luxury cars stolen in
California were driven to Nicaragua
where they were officially imported by
the Nicaraguan military to avoid stiff
excise taxes and sold to wealthy Managua
right the second number which is way
down here in Peru
it says mid late 1970s Peruvian cocaine
was smuggled to Panama secret in
suitcases and shoes with false bottoms
and carried into the US by airline
passengers points of entry included San
Francisco Los Angeles Houston and New
Orleans
the third one is late 1970s 283 cocaine
from the new Cali cartel in Colombia was
loaded onto freighters owned by the
Grande Colombian line the freighters
were offloaded in the ports of Los
Angeles San Francisco Portland and
Seattle for early 1980s cocaine was
flown from Colombia to the Bahamas where
it was loaded aboard small planes and
flown into Miami from their couriers
will take it to California aboard
commercial airliners right I can go on
about this but where did you get the new
information you know it's been public
record for you know 20 years almost well
it was just from court files I mean
eventually once in a while they would
catch one of these people the DEA would
file an affidavit and lay out what they
knew about the drug rings operations and
it came from you know a lot of stuff in
national archives mostly a lot of these
old court cases and then there were
cases in Nicaragua which laid out the
smuggling routes through that country
into the United States we had the back
end of it as well Gary Webb Jack Nelson
is at the table I do want to tell the
audience something because right over
your head you can't see they look up on
that screen there when we have it it
looks like there's a crack in the window
but that's actually condensation on our
window back here because it's so muggy
and it comes right down Jack's head so I
wanted to let you wouldn't believe how
muddy it can get here and watch
yes Jack Nelson escalade yeah I was
going to ask you because I haven't read
the series it looks fantastic but what
about the CIA involvement and all this
is that what the that that part of the
story deals with the the SDN that the
guerrilla army is that I mentioned
earlier that was you know as the
iran-contra hearings documented prevail
that was a creation of the CIA right and
we track the cocaine dealers who were
running this operation all the way up
the ladder to I cut the couple of CIA
agents that were actually running the
FTN Enrique Bermudez and Adolfo Calero
and a lot
let me tell let me tell you it's a bit
of background most of this information
much of the information came out at a
trial in San Diego in March one of the
one of the cocaine brokers the guy named
Danilo Blandon who was the head of the
Southern California operation it has
been working for the US government for
the last couple of years and he was the
star witness in a cocaine trafficking
trial for the DEA in San Diego and a lot
of this stuff came out under
cross-examination when he was up on the
witness stand because you know the
defense was curious to say the least
about his relationship with the Contras
and the Crips and unfortunately they
couldn't really get into a lot of it
because before the trial the United
States filed a motion asking that nobody
be allowed to ask mr. Blandon about his
relationship with the CIA and it was one
of those curious documents that ever
seen it said if true this matter would
be classified and their fault it
shouldn't be allowed of the trial so
didn't we had a chance to quiz him
greater detail about his relationship
did you get any help at all obviously I
oh it ain't during the investigation
absolutely not they wouldn't return my
phone calls I mean I filed a Freedom of
Information Act request for information
on Blandon and his boss Norwin Meneses
and I was told that they can't tell me
anything because the matter of national
security Gary where are you from ERISA
my dad was in the Marines so I'm from
everywhere and how long you've been with
the San Jose Mercury
News I've been with the mercury eight
years I was with a Cleveland Plain
Dealer five years before that where do
you go to college I went to college in
Indiana for a year and then I went to
college in Kentucky we're at Indiana
University
yeah IU in Indianapolis with commuter
college and I had a scholarship there
and then my dad got transferred and I
ended up at Northern Kentucky University
we're going to take a call a moment but
in your stories also you say that the
Crips and the Bloods the gang and the
gangs in LA I get involved in this how
that's the back end of the deal that's
who was buying the cocaine and they were
they were buying cocaine they were
buying weapons from these fellows how
how much can give us some sense of how
big this thing is um well you know I one
of the guys that talked to me was was
the guy who was buying at a fella named
freeway Rick Ross he was the biggest
crack wholesaler in Los Angeles during
the 1980s and he says well he and Danilo
Blandon has both said that you know at
their peak they were doing 100 kilos a
week and that's just for that's just
with one dealer you know I don't know
how how much Blandon was selling to
other people but with Rick Ross he was
selling at least 100 kilos a week by
1984-1985 let's take a call and Jack
Nelson's here at the desk with us and
we'll ask both of you gentlemen to get
involved Wellington Delaware go ahead
please hi Maureen I'm a little nervous
because it's my first time that's all
right join the club if you ever remember
doing the CIA Contra hearings when ally
north and President Reagan and all those
other people were having this war in
Nicaragua this information came out then
but it was just you know put on as a rug
but it's what was a new well-known fact
at the time that the CIA was using gangs
in California in various parts of the
country black groups and they would
bring drugs into the United States and
they are part of the reason why the drug
situation is the way it is the day
because they infiltrated the country but
all these drugs so they could get the
money because Congress would not
appropriate money for us to carry on
that war in Nicaragua where is they how
to get money from someplace to finance
the war but what about right now though
what do you think the situation is I ask
all of you what's the status of this
drug-running today well I don't know
what the situation is now but the CIA is
one of the reasons why the situation is
what it is today
all right thanks caller mr. Webb what do
you say today whether this was his
liaison exist today right
I don't know um I mean I found that did
these guys were deep buying and selling
from the same sources up until 1992 and
blendin was finally arrested by the DEA
so I mean it was going on at least until
92 what do you think
my guess is not I mean I wouldn't I mean
I can't believe for example that Judge
William Webster who I've known for a
long time who was the ie director would
not have tried to put a stop to anything
like that when he was CIA director and
that mr. Dorsey current CIA director uh
I can't believe that he would any
welcome no I'm not saying that the CIA
is necessarily involved in oh I know
you're not know I know you're not saying
it yeah but I'm just saying I don't I
don't think so that was an absolute
Brian's question I know you didn't say
that Gary well in some later items here
on your pipeline chart says in late
1980s combien cocaine was flown aboard
private planes into small airfields in
northern Costa Rica and southern
Nicaragua super dc-3 is leaving from San
Jose Costa Rica loaded with general
merchandise would touch down briefly
take on a cocaine load and continue on
to US airports spring that came out of
the trial that a Nicaragua spring Norwin
Meneses the guy who was running this
program thanks Springfield Missouri
you're next
yeah Brian I'm really disappointed in
you I really am that is the whole theme
in this is that the CIA was what was was
bringing or was supplying the the
Contras with guns and and and and
financing it off drugs is that's the
theme and the only the only the only
source we have for this is some some
questionable character this is like the
Gary sick thing all over and let me let
me have you read the series no I had not
the only source that's the only source
we've talked about that's the only
source you've talked about we had we had
like seven or eight independent sources
on this stuff and contemporaneous outlet
you you have
larger names pardon no names
well where do you want me to start rough
start
you've got a kitchen John Dorian filed
an affidavit in Los Angeles what hope
was I correct on the theme with this
whole thing that the CIA was applying
the Contras of guns and financing the
whole thing off off of drugs no that's
not correct well I'm certainly supplying
with guns they weren't financing the
whole thing off of drugs they were
financing part of it off the drugs part
of it well parts even bad but well I
tend to agree but I don't know it I'm
disappointing Brian he puts experts on
for the fur for scandals for for though
he hadn't put any experts that know
about scandals for for Clinton but yet
he puts on these stupid ad scandal still
I mean he's back in the past all right
hold on just a second well I don't Gary
we're the community in Los Angeles
thinks it's a stupid scandal let me just
tell the caller why this gentleman's on
here it's because collar after collar
kept calling up and referring to this
whole subject it seems the first thing
you do is you go to the source and ask
what it's all about and then we can
continue talking about this I don't
blame you for being upset we have we
can't deal with this thing in 15 minutes
that's from the White House is it to put
this
Yubel another not now there's now
there's once there's see there's one of
your clothes Republican Democrat
Republican there's no color there's not
even a sand we haven't talked to the
White House forever and this whole thing
is yeah well who did you bad -
somebody's pressure
we didn't buy anybody's price all come
as they come we did
oh he's upset about the calls that you
know the Democrat Republican Democratic
but why don't you just let the calls you
say that the caller this guy's got a
place on the program I don't care he's
got political agenda he's upset because
we split the call lines Gary Webb you
want to talk some more about your
sources on this thing and who will not
talk who just absolutely won't talk the
seat we file Freedom of Information Act
request with the CIA and and as I said
those were those were denied a national
security grounds we file them with the
DEA and for the first time in my life I
think the DEA came
and said no we don't want to give you
any records because we're concerned
about invading the privacy of these drug
dealers so we don't want to tell you
about them so they can give us anything
the FBI sent me a letter saying it might
be two years before they got around to
answering my request the AI NS has never
responded the State Department has
gotten the stuff and never responded I
mean so and these have been filed for
like six eight months and then we tried
asking the DEA questions that we
couldn't get any answer from them the
only thing that CIA says is it's
ludicrous which you know I'll be the
first to agree it's the idea of them
selling drugs to the Contras for the
Contras the crypsis is ludicrous but
everything we saw said it was true let's
grab a call from Dayton Ohio go ahead
please hi the one question that no one's
asked yet and I'm going to ask it and
see if this guy give us an honest answer
where these drugs targeted to black
people I don't think they were targeted
like in in the manner that you mean they
were targeted in in so far as you know
Danilo Blandon the man who was who was
sent to Los Angeles to sell these drugs
he had a master's degree in marketing
that was his job before the Revolution
he was in charge of setting up wholesale
markets for Nicaraguan agricultural
produce he came to the United States and
testified and again it he isn't the only
one that says this but he said this
under oath while as a government witness
he wasn't trying to beat a rap he wasn't
trying to reduce a sentence he's a free
man and he came into court and testified
to this under oath and what he said was
that he was schooled in San Francisco in
the drug trade took us two days to teach
him how to because I'm a cocaine dealer
he went down in Los Angeles and didn't
know what to do and when you talked to
his friends and you took at the
documents that exist
what happened that apparently was you
know the guy's a marketing expert he
looked around he saw where it wasn't
being sold and went to sell it there I
mean I think it was as simple as that I
don't think anybody really cared
particularly where he got the money as
long as you got it that we're about
we're going to get time for me at least
one more call but I want to ask you
because the caller who was upset about
this being set up by the White House let
me bring in the Mena Arkansas story that
the Wall Street Journal spent a lot of
time on well I we wrote about that the
other day
how does that fit in with all this I
mean this was Maina was a parallel main
it was part of a parallel operation that
was going on on the East Coast which is
why if people think they've heard about
this before it's because they heard
about the East Coast pipeline when it
was uncovered back in 85 and 86 but I
want to make the connection but the
current president is he was supposedly
involved as a governor well he was
governor while this was going on whether
or not he knew about it is something I
don't think it's been proven yet let me
ask Jack Nelson about this did you pay
do you paint hissing that mean Arkansas
story
well we've written what was there but I
mean there's no indication that that
Clinton is governor had anything to do
with it I mean it's been it's been
written about with all sorts of
speculation by a lot of right-wing
publications but I've never seen
anything that that indicated any
complicity on the part of the president
Gary Webb if people want to get a copy
of this I understand that you have
reprints for a small fee I think
actually they decided to make a pre but
it's you can call four oh eight nine to
oh five nine nine nine or you can
download the whole thing from the
internet I will with all our
documentation with with sound clips so
you can hear Danilo Blandon testifying
to this in his own words and you can get
that at WWJ mercury dot-com slash drugs
that's the best version actually all
right let's do that one again so the
people who can write it down wws J
mercury SJ mercury Kham Kham flash drug
drugs and if again that telephone number
if you want it and that soon there's no
one there now well there might be
machine there now you can leave a name
and number four oh eight nine - oh five
nine nine nine are you alleging at any
of this that the Republicans had
anything to do with this as a party no I
mean we we tried to stay I to stay was
far out of partisan politics on the
stories I could just tell a story about
a drug operation you know it we we
mentioned obviously the Reagan was in
power when he authorized this the secret
war down there but you know Clinton's in
power now now those are the folks who
put the Nilo blend down on the federal
payroll I mean the guy brought crack
- la is now federal government employee
all right Virginia Beach Virginia go
ahead please yes concerning they
Arkansas involvement and the drug thing
ever since 1986 Bill Clinton as governor
did not ride hurt on this thing but all
the drugs all the drugs came through
Mena Arkansas everybody knows that and
read it in the papers Barry seal was
doing it Barry seal was killed Clinton
didn't really have anything to do with
accepting you bet it gave Oscar Stewart
wrote hurt on it and his government bond
program received ten percent of the
profits plus all the money was able to
be laundered through Arkansas banks all
right thanks mr. Webb that's that's a
lot of the allegations around Mena and a
lot of what she said is true um that the
Barry seal was I mean he was one of the
biggest drug dealers in the country at
the time and that's where his that's
where he was based on a mr. Nelson
Freedom of Information Act is that made
any difference yes in some cases it has
I mean we've been able to get files from
the FBI in some cases I did for the book
I got a lot of my information that I did
on tearing the night plans campaign
against the Jews what about that mr.
Webb do you would be the one we had that
worked which I mean sort of cemented the
story for us was the Freedom of
Information Act we filed with the
National Archives and those folks over
there released some FBI documents that
have been classified for about ten years
regarding regarding this drug ring
regarding this operation and we got them
out of the the files of iran-contra
special prosecutor Lawrence Walsh and
these are some of the FBI reports that
were done either prior to the Walsh
investigation as part of something else
or as part of the Walsh investigation
let's go to Newport Rhode Island next go
ahead please yes mr. Webb this is a very
interesting conversation you should also
check at the National Archives the
recently released documents on the board
of economic warfare from world war ii
which was founded by William Casey who
worked it who was a part of the old OSS
yeah and they they began by purchasing
the first crop of opium that they
purchased the entire crop from Turkey
was 1943 Lucky Luciano moved
and was deported to Naples after he
helped with the invasion of Sicily
Luciano began his operas heroin
trafficking from Turkey through Naples
Sicily and if you almost fall ya know
the pre-emptive buys what the board of
economic warfare was about the reason
why I'm interested in it is some
characters in your part of the country
were on the board of economic warfare as
that okay and so and I Oh anyway so um
it's been going on for a long long time
and it's and then of course it's not a
logical thing that Casey would be
involved in this type of operation in
the nineteen eighties
thanks mr. Rosell well it sounds like
Gary's got himself another story there
yeah I got somebody doesn't it's I was
gonna say if somebody doesn't beat you
to it Gary but it did sound in what you
said now this isn't the best way to get
a story right well you know when you sit
and listen to everybody on this thing
you start to hear all the conspiracy
theories well yeah they come to you in a
big way I mean you find people come out
of the woodwork because they're but they
follow these kind of things yeah yeah
that's that's sort of sort of one of the
risks is doing this kind of story and
and frankly I mean the thing that gave
us the the sort of you know intestinal
fortitude to do this because we realize
this is a very controversial story this
is like almost impossible to leave
believe when you look at it but we've
got this tool now called the World Wide
Web where you can you can show people
the documents you used I mean we you can
click on a we can read the story and if
it says set a report you can click on
the word report and actually read the
report if we've got a quote in there and
it's highlighted you can written
actually read the report if you've got a
quote in there and it's highlighted you
can hear what these folks said so in May
you know make up your own lines don't
take my word for you know nobody knows
who I am you know what I was listening
to that radio station I don't remember
which radio station and don't mention it
please because I'm going to say
something that they won't like you were
set up before you got on in a way you
probably didn't even know about you a
really right and I just wondered how
often I mean that the the fellow that
was
the host had an agenda he talked about
you in a specific way and by the time
you got on I was listening thinking I
wonder if mr. Webb has any idea what
he's been saying before you get on the
air no I have none tell me about it well
I you know I can't hear on the air
because I don't I don't remember the
name I don't remember the station and I
don't want to say anything that would be
the one I can't remember what he did was
sandbagging is that right well not
necessary because he was very much in
favor of what he had done oh so it was
just but it was in a certain way that he
set it up and and you got the distinct
impression he was just you know
overwhelmingly delighted that you had
done this and for a lot of political
reasons and he was talking about let's
take one more call for you then we'll
let you go
Lawrenceburg Tennessee go ahead please
good morning Brian morning it's a thrill
to get through you guys I've had the TV
turned on so long a fella lost track of
the conversation your screener said to
earnest said one of the things that had
caught my interest when you first
brought the gentleman on about the
investigation of the CIA involvement in
the drug traffic Los Angeles was when
you showed his chart would to understand
he couldn't see at the time it showed
all the different points where the drugs
had entered the country and I couldn't
read the chart well enough to know if
the area down there around the Gulf
included being Arkansas or not you know
this Mena Arkansas thing has been going
on that accusation has been made now
ever since Clinton came into office
especially tying him and Don Lassiter
and the other gentleman that right was
the supposedly the head man in that part
of the country so wait we've got all
tied together yeah we've talked about it
and now let mr. Webb answer you go ahead
actually actually to give you a bit of
background I mean Maina just became an
issue since Clinton became president but
the information has been available since
the kha'ri Committee did its
investigation back in 87 and 88 a lot of
what I know about mana came from reading
the report free reading from reading the
report of that investigation as I said
you know they were on to this East Coast
contra pipeline which they exposed
pretty well for some reason that report
just never had any resonance with with
the media
what's your follow up on all this you
know obviously now
things going with doges asked for an
investigation for the CIA inspector
general that's one one thing we're
looking at there is a lot of talk
especially among the Congressional Black
Caucus about doing hearings on this
thing which is which is another issue
and then there's a didn't you get the
role of the DEA and the Justice
Department in this thing and Ben and
Barbara Boxer and Dianne Feinstein are
both asked for investigations on that so
there's number investigations going on
in Washington we're going to be proud on
Gary Webb five a.m. out there thanks a
lot forgetting I'm telling us about this
sure glad glad to be here and as we will
give out the telephone number one more
time if you want to get the documents
408 nine to zero five nine nine nine in
your life of as a journalist what
articles have you written that got the
most impact I mean worse you know he's
talking about hearings happening and all
those kind of stuff CIA director getting
involved well I guess the most impact I
had was the series I did on a mental
institution the largest mental
institution in the world in
Milledgeville Georgia which had no
12,500 patients in 2,500 more on an
outpatient basis and I did a series of
stories that showed that the chief
surgeon err was was away from the
hospital at times while a nurse was who
was his close friend was performing
major surgery on patients where another
drug doctor was giving experimental
drugs to mental patients where they only
spent two dollars and 52 cents a day for
the care feeding and housing of each
mental patient I mean it was a it was a
snake pit and it was a big investigation
later and they fired a bunch of people
including the superintendent hospital
and I had a written big mental health
reform there so that probably was the
most thanks for staying later yeah okay
I'm glad I'm glad I got here on time
again we had our in for five minutes out
of you thank you very much Jack Nelson
who is the chief Washington
correspondent for the LA Times and
Charlie Peters and Ken Tomlinson up next
after a short break